hi there today we're looking at
transformers or rnns fast autoregressive
transformers with linear attention by
angle Oh Scott ro Poulos app or via
nikolaos Papa's and Fon suavely hey so
this paper on a high level proposes to
interpret the attention mechanism in
transformers with a in terms of a kernel
function and therefore the resulting
higher dimensional linear operation can
be used to formulate the linear
transformer which is orders of magnitude
faster than a classic transformer they
also show that in the case of
autoregressive transformers this makes
the transformer essentially equivalent
to a special kind of RN n so yeah that's
that's what this paper is about and I
think some comments to make that I
haven't really seen made by others
though I have to admit also haven't
really looked at many comments so I I
might just be telling old boring things
as always if you like content like this
consider sharing it out leave a like if
you liked it leave a comment to you know
let me know what you think I do read the
comments and they're generally comments
section is very very helpful and to me
and also people you know respond to each
other it's it's fairly cool to see that
the community is usually very helpful to
people asking questions and yeah just
let me know what do you think alright so
what's the problem with transformers and
I've done many videos on transformers
and I you know keep referring back to
them for people who don't know what it
is but there's this original paper
called attention is all you need that
where I made a video about that so if
you don't know what transformers are you
can go look at that that should
basically cover everything you need to
know but there's many more transformers
in the meantime there's Burt GPT to GPT
whatever the number is after that many
sequence processing models are now
transformers many set processing models
are now transfer
so this has reached a very very made a
very big splash in the community so
essentially transformers come with this
attention mechanism where you have an
input set actually but let's consider it
a sequence so a sequence of texts maybe
like I have an ice cream cone something
like this and you want to classify the
text or you want to perform language
modeling so in language modeling the
problem is as follows I give you this
piece of text and I ask you to predict
the next piece of text this is this was
kind of the first task that these
transformers were used on and this is
what is called an autoregressive
transformer because you always have a
piece you predict the next piece and
then I give you that next it gives you
that entire piece and then you predict
the next piece yet again and so on and
this auto regressive property is gonna
you know come in play in this paper
later but ultimately what you have in a
transformer is called an attention
mechanism so an attention mechanism is
the following each layer in the
transformer you can imagine as having
the same number of nodes kind of same
number of neurons as the secret your
sequence is long now from this input
sequence you're going to generate for
each of these tokens you're going to
generate three different things you're
going to generate a key query in the
value so and in this you do from so
usually this doesn't come in form of a
letter right this comes in form of some
kind of embedding vector and from that
you're going to generate three different
things I should probably use different
colors for sure so this is a function
you're going to produce three different
things from that you're going to produce
a key you're going to produce a query
and you're going to produce a value now
the key is you can imagine it being
attached to this lower layer right here
so that's the key for this this token
right here that's the key the key here
for that token right here it's a word
piece right so the keys again are also
you know vectors vector vector the query
you figuratively attach to the top layer
right here so the queries they go here
for each token and they are also vectors
and the values will keep out of it for
now so the queries and the keys defined
basically how you go out the information
and you route the information by going
over each so each each you have to
imagine each token right here this this
have or have it needs to aggregate
information from all the other tokens
right so we're going to through multiple
layers of this and in each layer each of
these tokens is aggregating information
from the other tokens if we do this in
multiple rounds is eventually you know
the each token is aggregating
information eventually each token knows
about all the other tokens but how this
information aggregation is done is very
important for example if the token is a
pronoun it would be very interested in
information coming from any sort of
named entity in the sentence because it
very much wants to know what it is
referring to right if you are a if you
are the pronoun in the sentence it is
very vital that you understand which of
these things you refer to so you'll
start aggregating information for that
and then once you know who or what you
refer to then the other parts of the
sentence can make use of that
information so they will start
requesting information from you and so
layer after layer each token aggregates
information from each other
token so this works by let's say we're
at this token right here what we're
going to do is we're going to form the
inner product between that vector and
each of these vectors and then we're
going to transfer that into a soft Max
which makes this into a first of all
there's so we do the query together with
all the keys
and then we run it through the
exponential function and after that
we're going to normalize it by the sum
of all the exponential functions that
will give us a properly normalized
distribution so a histogram basically of
where we are going to get our
information from this is going to be the
highest where the inner product right
here is the highest so from this token
right here and you know this is fairly
fairly standard what I drew by accident
is fairly standard that a token probably
wants to know a lot about itself so you
want to carry forward the information
that you already have in this particular
token that's why your inner products
going to maybe align a lot with your own
key so the keys and queries are learned
so each token decides what kind of
information it wants to advertise to the
others and then also each token
decides what kind of information it
wants to gather from the others and the
routing then is put through a softmax
function and that gives you this right
here you do this for every single token
so the problem with this is that every
single token needs to do the inner
product of its query with all the
different keys and each of that has to
go through the softmax and then the
value that's actually aggregated are
these values right here now the values
are simply a transformation of the
incoming values values are what's really
propagated you can think of it as just
like a one layer neural network
ultimately you could also leave away the
values people don't do this some people
do the same queries and keys but the
values are just a transformation of your
input so the important thing is this
right here this decides how you're going
to aggregate the values all right so
this is has a quadratic complexity so if
you if you have n input tokens then this
entire process will require
n-squared operations because you need to
form the inner products between each
pair of calories and keys right and it
also is going to require that much
memory and this we're going to see this
is in large part due to this softmax
operation because because we have a soft
max it makes the whole thing nonlinear
and it being nonlinear basically means
we'll have to you know store everything
keep everything around and we have to
recompute for each query we're going to
see in this paper formulation where if
we make the whole process linear then we
will not have to do that
so let's dive into it so here they go
linear transformers they start off with
saying each transformer layer is
essentially this right here so this is a
this is kind of a higher level of you
what we viewed so far is just this part
right here this is the attention routing
mechanism each layer is actually wrapped
in a residual connection and also a
simple element wise or row-wise
feed-forward layer but these things are
usually not that much into consideration
what's really hurting in the transformer
if you go into very long sequences is
this attention routing mechanism so the
attention routing mechanism is as
follows you can see right here this is
the formal expression of what I
described right here
here you have the end notice this is an
outer product so if if I have if I have
n sequence elements the queue right here
are the queries so this transforms each
of the n into a into a d-dimensional
space right and also the keys will
transform each of these into a
d-dimensional space so this here is
going this here is going to be a n by n
matrix right this is this Q K T is going
to be an N by n matrix this is a
WQ WK x and this transposed right here
nope yeah like this okay so this is sort
of an outer product and then we're going
to take the row-wise softmax
and that will give us for each row in
this matrix so for each row in this
matrix we're going to have these dis
distribution of how to aggregate
information each row will give us
basically for each of the upper-level
tokens for each of the outputs how we
need to aggregate information from the
inputs and the information that we're
aggregating are these values right here
now they generalize this first of all
they say we can also we can write it in
this form right here instead of having a
soft max we can actually think of any
kind of similarity function it between
the queries and the keys so here you see
what we want to do if we want to
calculate output I here the important
thing is there is no longer this is an
entire matrix and we considered a row
wise softmax and now we write this out
into the individual elements of the
output and we can we can do so I mean
say okay how do we obtain one element of
the output we're going to calculate some
sort of similarity of that particular
Creasy I hear I hear we're going to
calculate some sort of similarity
between the query of that particular
output with all of the keys so here you
can see all of the keys of the input and
we're going to act and we're going to
normalize right this is the
normalization that happens also in the
softmax and that will give us like a
histogram of how we aggregate the values
right here so all of this of this red
stuff will give us again some sort of a
histogram of how we're going to
aggregate information
if you look a bit like this and you know
how the softmax is defined you'll see
that if we plug in the exponential
function for as the similarity function
then you'll get back to the softmax okay
these they say equation 3 is equivalent
to equation 2 if we substitute the
similarity function with the exponential
function now they go to go ahead and
they go into kernels so for that you
sort of need to understand what a kernel
is a kernel is a special kind for the
purposes that we are you know looking at
here a kernel is a special kind of a
similarity function it needs to have
some properties right here but
essentially they say well this this kind
of looks like a kernel and we will
simply say okay here this similarity
what if we use a kernel here so a kernel
simply is a similarity function of two
vectors if you interpret it like it has
some more conditions I know and now
don't freak on me but the interesting
properties about kernels is that if a
similarity function is a kernel it means
that there exists a mapping and where do
we do so if K between a and B is a
kernel if K is a kernel that means that
there exists a similar a function Phi
such that Phi such that the kernel
between a and B can be expressed as a
linear product between 5a and Phi of B
transpose okay this is like this is an
inner product so what it means is that
this can be like a super nonlinear
function a kernel for example it can be
and the example often given in like
learning classes is maybe something like
this you have one dimensional data right
and here is the here is zero and you
have two kinds of data points you have
the X's right here and you have the
circles right here now I cannot classify
this data linearly however however I can
transform this into a higher dimensional
space so my function Phi is of my
function Phi of X is going to map to the
vector X x squared and that will
transform the data into a
two-dimensional space right and the data
will look something like this so it's
going to the y axis is going to be the
square of the x axis okay and like this
and now I can find a linear classifier
okay so in this case right here you can
see that in this higher space things
become linear things become linearly
classifiable and very similarly like
this is you can define the similarity
between things right here so the
similarity function would be the square
function right here and this would be a
quadratic an example of a quadratic
kernel so this function right here can
be very non linear I mean it can be a
linear function but it can be very non
linear but it is equivalent it is
equivalent this means it is equivalent
to a linear function in a high
dimensional space now to figure out
linear to figure out what this function
Phi is is the big the big question of
course for a couple of kernels we know
the function Phi right for the quadratic
kernel for example we know we just saw
that Phi Maps this to the vector of the
coordinate end
it's quadratic too it's square we know
for a couple of other kernels what their
Associated functions are but in general
if it's a kernel then we can just
replace it with a linear function M with
with with this thing and in Reverse we
can just say well what we could do is we
could just simply define a function Phi
and basically map this into map these a
and B into a higher dimensional space
where this super duper nonlinear
function would just become a linear
function wouldn't that be much easier
linear functions are much easier to work
with and long nonlinear functions and if
we know that as long as we get the
correct Phi we do exactly the same thing
as the nonlinear function you know that
would be helpful so there is an entire
literature in the entire like decade of
kernelization and kernel eyes everything
kernel eyes SVM's to start but then you
can go way further in this and this is
just the beginning and this is just a
very sloppy explanation by me right here
but ultimately they're saying hey
instead of doing complicated nonlinear
similarity function like the softmax
can't we just project a and B into the
higher dimensional space and then just
do the linear inner product and do the
same thing as the softmax and the answer
is yes and no we know that for the
softmax the particular phi function that
we would need would map to an infinite
dimensional space usually usually this
is applied in Reverse it's like oh here
instead usually in machine learning if
they say you know we want to do this we
want to map it into a high dimensional
space that is linear but we we can't
because these spaces are too high
dimensional and therefore we find an
equivalent kernel function and it's
usually said well we've used an RBF
kernel that corresponds to an infinite
dimensional space and so on that's
pretty cool here it's the reverse here
it's we want to do we want to leave
function we and the equivalent of the
softmax function is an
infinite-dimensional function which we
can't do right we can't feasibly compute
an infinite dimensional space explicitly
so it's not possible to just do the
equivalent thing than in a transformer
however you can still do something else
you can still use polynomial kernels you
can still use any kind of kernels that
have corresponding functions that map to
a finite dimensional space and that's
what this paper does so here they say if
we have such a function that map's these
things into a higher dimensional space
such that their inner product such that
the similarity function in this higher
dimensional space is an inner product
then we can write it as just this inner
product right here explicitly and then
because of the associativity you can see
that here is an i and here there is no I
so we can just sort of pull this out of
this sum and as well right here it
doesn't don't don't cross this away
these are vectors right but you can see
especially here you can see pretty clear
why is there a cursor stop you can see
that this here you have to pay attention
to the matrix dimension so if we use
like bracket notation this is like this
like this like this and like this okay
so here on the bottom you see that there
is an inner product so each output will
be normalized by this inner product
right here
however the top is going to be a vector
we know that you know each output is a
vector so the top will aggregate these
vectors right here according to this
routing okay but if we write it like
this you can see that what we could
technically do is we could technically
compute this part here once because it
doesn't contain any I so
no I in that part so we could just
compute it once because we have these
two these two layers of the attention
mechanism and these K and V they just
refer to this lower layer right here we
could just compute that thing on the
right once that's going to give us a
matrix as you can see right here from
the dimensions and then we can simply
take the product of that vector right
here of the vector on the left with the
matrix on the right and we be done it's
one operation right instead of for each
thing you know going and attending to
each other and then do these softmax
without the softmax we can all do this
in a linear fashion so that makes it a
lot easier in fact it makes the
computation linear in so this is now o
of n okay plus of course the work that
you have to do for mapping this into the
higher dimensional space but this is
also not quadratic this is done to each
of these elements individually okay so
this this is now as we said it's pretty
easy you can calculate the matrix on the
top you can actually also calculate this
part right here this vector you can
aggregate over the bottom and then if
you go through the top it's simply a
inner product with the vector of the
queries and you're done
and this is it in fact in matrix form
you can simply write it down as one
matrix multiplication seems pretty easy
so the computational cost goes way down
and they use the following function
right here okay this is their map to the
higher dimensional
to the higher dimensional space so they
say for our experiments that deal with
smaller sequences we employ a feature
map that results in a positive
similarity function as defined below so
right here you have to pay attention you
can't just pick any function
but you can you can pick a lot of
different functions where a lute denotes
the exponential linear unit activation
function okay like this seems this seems
fine
they also say in our experimental
section we show that the feature map of
equation seven performs on par with the
full transformer while significantly
reducing the computational memory
requirements this you know it seems it
seems like the the original transformer
this choice of the softmax function even
though it's you know powerful and can't
be approximated with this trick right
here
it was also somewhat arbitrary I mean
there is a reasoning behind it but it's
also somewhat like and it's entirely
possible right that that this here is
way faster so I want to jump this causal
masking thing for now and look at the
results where you can see they verify
the fact that in terms of time in terms
of GPU memory if they apply their
transformer and here on the x-axis is
the sequence length and you can see that
the this is log plot right these are log
plots you can see that the original
transformer right here has a way steeper
slope then their transformer which is
the black line right here the blue lines
are the reformers which we've also I've
also done a video on reformer if you
want to check that out that is also a
trick that uses locality sensitive
hashing to get rid of the quadratic
attention mechanism now the locality
sensitive hashing also means that you
kind of lose some accuracy so that's the
trade off right here but you can see
that is also linear actually it's n log
n depending on the sequence length but
the log n is negligible so you see GPU
memory and time way down and in terms of
experiments it does perform on par it
seems like it has different optimization
trajectory but they show that you know
there is this trade-off for the reformer
where you
lose an accuracy they do not experience
that trade-off in the linear transformer
compared to the original transformer in
their particular experiments now they do
their experiments sort of show that they
are not on par with the original
transfer like they are on par in some of
the tasks but also in some of the tasks
they are not on par for example this
speech data set right here where they do
fairly well they actually beat the pile
STM baseline and the reformer but they
do not beat the softmax transformer so
there there's it is still the case that
the softmax transformer is more powerful
than the thing here and will give some
intuition very shortly on that but the
linear transformer is way faster here
it's three times faster and up here it
is 300 times faster and LM nest and if
you go and see 410 is 4,000 times faster
simply by a property of the longer
either your sequences are that you input
the much more matters the fact that the
softmax transformer has a quadratic
runtime whereas the linear transformer
has a linear runtime and I was also
surprised here to see that the reformer
wasn't that much faster that's probably
due to the fact that it already has like
a big overhead in these hashing rounds
and so on that probably is hurting it at
sort of a constant level I guess if you
were to up the sequence length even more
than the reformer would also improve a
lot more over the softmax transformer
okay so what's what's happening here
what's happening with these with this
attention and why is it different what
does it makes it different from the old
attention now I want to I want to sort
of connect this to the kind of old and
old the olden literature of topic
modeling so if you think of the of this
transformer again of this
ancient mechanism what you'll have is a
dynamic routing of information right so
from each from each output token you get
to look at all the input tokens if we
for example select this one you get to
look and you get to decide for each one
how do I want to aggregate my
information okay and this is what makes
this quadratic from each of the output
tokens you get to look on all of the
input tokens and decide how you want to
do that and that is can be very long
nonlinear in terms of when we use these
softmax and so on so that what makes it
expensive what this thing is doing is
the following he takes all the keys
right here so here we have all the keys
and it's going to map them through this
five function right each key is going to
map through the five function and each
query is also going to be mapped through
the Phi function into these higher
dimensional spaces and then an inner
product is performed between the two and
that decides the routing this is very
similar to like topic models where if
you interpret this this right here can
be a mapping of my dimension of these
keys and queries to the topics so
essentially what's happening right here
is for each of the input tokens sorry
with input tokens here output tokens
here the dimension of this map defines
is how many topics there are so in you
know in these topics modeling you you
would have things like I want to
I have news articles or words and then I
define like a set of topics and I'm
going to assign each word to a topic and
then I'm going to assign each news
article to a topic and so on and then
you kind of do this dimension reduction
but this can be done in many ways so
let's say this is a mapping to three
dimensions what this does is essentially
this five function decides how you're
going to map each of these inputs into
these three topics so
you can say oh this token goes here and
here this one goes here and a bit here
this one goes here and so on so again
this is a this is a mapping into a well
in this case a lower dimensional space
and then this function decides how
you're going to a great these topics are
over across here and since this is you
know this is now a linear multiplication
between the two things so these two are
going to be your matrices this here is
going to be your Phi of K and this here
is going to be your Phi of Q so you can
see the difference here between the old
attention mechanism and the new
attention mechanism right the old
attention mechanism each token was
directly able to look at all the input
tokens and decide how to aggregate the
information and here it's sort of we
have this in between is in between
representation in this higher
dimensional space and we can aggregate
in only a we can distribute in a linear
fashion and we can aggregate in a linear
fashion in and from this higher
dimensional space that's sort of how how
I sort of how I imagined that okay so
you get to distribute each token right
here into these topics and then the the
outputs day they don't see the inputs
anymore right you see that in the
formulation there is a sum over J so
right here there is this sum over J and
that means that the outputs here they
don't see the different inputs as
different inputs they only see the
inputs through the map of the Phi
function so they can only see the
individual dimensions of that Phi
function they cannot see the outputs
anymore and therefore yeah
therefore you don't have the dependence
on the big quadratic dependence on this
on this n okay however you do have occur
of course now a dependence on this D
dimension
of the intermediate representation and
they also they say this right this is
reasonable yeah they do derive the
gradients here to save even more memory
so you don't have to such that you don't
have to let's say store of all of these
activations that's pretty cool as well
and they implemented in CUDA there is
code available for the linear
transformer all of this pretty pretty
cool okay so the last thing they say
they make the connections to are n ends
now this is a bit detached from the
linear transformer but because they
formulated how they do they can make
this connection so this now this now is
valid for all transformers what they say
right here but keep in mind it is valid
for the original transformers in
practice if you can make this mapping
Phi to map to infinite dimensions which
you can't but but the analysis is
equivalent so they say look if we write
the attention mechanism like this and
therefore like this what we can do is we
can define these two quantities right s
and Z and this is what we said before we
can actually pre compute these
quantities right here okay so that
reduces to this right here if now we are
looking at a autoregressive transformer
and we said before what an
autoregressive transformer was an
autoregressive transformers you have a
piece of sequence and you are tasked to
predict this next thing right here now
usually if you want to train this using
an RNN you have to you know run your RN
n input this hidden state and input that
map for with the hidden state so you
have to do all of this forward
propagation in order to derive at this
hidden s-- at this output right here
make the output and then you need to
back drop through time right here there
is no way to what you would like to do
is you would like to say here I have a
sentence
I can actually make like five different
training examples from that sentence so
the first one is the one you just saw I
just block off the last word but I can
also make that training example right
here right - Laurine I just cut a second
to last word and so on I can actually
make all of these different training
examples for a language modeling from a
single sentence and what I would like to
do is I would like to train them all in
parallel right dial out my data point
once I already have it why can't I just
train everything at the same time like
predict this from this word now predict
also this from these two words and the
Transformers are you know very well
conditioned they are very good at this
basically so what a transformer can do
is if you input a sequence like sorry
like the thing at the bottom you can
calculate the training signal for all of
these different things at the same time
and okay this was maybe a mistake you
can calculate the training signal for
all this at the same time by using
what's called causal masking in
attention so if I have my attention
mechanism right here let's consider it
again let's consider these two layers if
I have my attention mechanism what I
want to do is I want to constrain each
token to only attend two tokens that
came before it in the sequence so for
example this token right here I'm going
to constrain it to only attend to itself
and the past because it will it will
predict the next token in the sequence
and it wouldn't be it would be really
easy if we could attend to the input of
that token right it could simply
remember what that token is and then
aggravate that here and then predict
that so if for each token we restrict
the attention to the tokens that came
before it like also for this right here
we restrict the attention only to go
backwards
then we can train all of this in
parallel this is called causal masking
it's usually implemented with like a
mask that is like an upper diagonal and
it's a bit unclear if you can attend to
yours to yourself because then I guess
this will become the output and you can
only attend to this I don't know how
exactly how it is implemented
but there it is usually realized with an
upper triangular matrix as a mask and
you apply this mask to each layer now
they say that this is actually like an
orang n' and with their formulation you
can make this pretty explicit namely you
have these two states s and a Z and in
each sequence element it's actually like
an RNN where you update the s and z with
these quantities right here and so it's
like an RN and where these are the
hidden states that you pass forward
right and then you can formulate any
transformer as an RNN that simply
updates these two states but you see you
need the explicit mapping of these of
this kernel function you need these
explicit mapping in order to be able to
do this because otherwise this is here
this is not going to be a linear
addition it is going to be complicated
you can't do it by simply remembering
the past state so you need that
formulation in order to be able to
express it as an RNN but their analysis
shows that this a transformer
autoregressive is essentially an RNN and
you can you can so you can make a
connection in that and you can actually
formulate this as an RNN which means
that you can train in the transformer
fashion everything at the same time but
what is cool about an RNN an RNN at
inference time an RNN once it has
produced you know this word it can then
because if you produce order
aggressively you simply say hey I have
this beginning of my news
article please finish it so the model
must output the next word and then from
that sequence it must output the neck
spurt the next word and then from that
the next word and so on and RNN
because of the nature of simply passing
forward hidden states and inference time
can simply you know remember what the
hidden States were input those again
input the output here and go on so it's
pretty fast at inference time which a
transformer isn't with their formulation
now if they have the explicit function
Phi they can use this at inference time
to be so much faster in fact on their
website which a link of course in the in
the description you can play with image
generation using one of these
transformers in your browser so you can
simply start a transformer run in your
browser that's how easy this becomes so
you can see the linear transformer with
causal masking you'll simply update
these states right here and then pass
those forward so easy and the backward
pass as we said I don't want to go into
the gradient calculation but they derive
the gradient such that you don't have to
remember these hidden states and it
becomes or it is linear in or it saves a
lot of more memory than before okay note
so this is the last comment from my side
note that this this causal masking
transformers they are they are a bit of
a hack in transformers and because so
ultimately let's say let's say I have
this sequence right here this is given
and I want to predict this word right
here what and okay let's make it up here
so I need multiple layers for this so I
want to predict that next word and I
have multiple layers right so I want to
predict this from from the outputs right
here let's say there is an output node
right here I want
to predict that particular word it's
true that I should only be able to
aggregate information from whatever was
you know on the back right here but
technically in a transformer it would be
completely valid to say that this node
right here which is let's say that's an
article and it followed by a noun right
would be able to attend to that one and
then that one would be able to attend to
that one and or sorry the output right
here would be able to attend to that one
this would not violate the
autoregressive properly right you can
but you can see that in the intermediate
layer this node right here is attending
to a forward node now if you do things
like this you can't do this trick
anymore where you train everything at
once because if if this connection
exists that also means that if in this
other training sample where this is the
word to be predicted then this node
could aggregate information from that
node and basically cheat but the the
technical autoregressive property is not
violated by this connection right here
and you only get this RNN formulation if
you do not have these connections right
so the this this hack to make the
autoregressive transformers train in
parallel is actually making the
transformer formulation much weaker and
therefore that's then equivalent to an
RNN okay I did it's not that
transformers in general or equivalent to
an ordinance or at least this paper
doesn't show that it's just that these
hacked transformers are and I think
that's an important distinction to make
here rather than saying transformers are
are n ends if we could only approximate
the softmax in these infinite dimensions
I don't think that's entirely true but
it is true for the Transformers the
autoregressive transformers that we
currently train now why is this
connection so powerful it allows at
how can to attend to you know tokens
forward of it and what does it mean to
be able to attend like let's say it's
really important that this token right
here attends to that token right here
what would you need to do if you
couldn't do that if you let's let's
let's say this is a program right so
this token is the function f and it
needs the input in this argument a of
whatever token comes in front of it and
it needs to do something conditioned on
a so if a if a is 1 it does something if
a is 2 it does something else right if
you if you don't have if you can't input
a then you can't simply pass on the
output value what you'll have to do is
conceptually is basically you'll have to
store the entire code of the function
into hidden state if this is an RNN
right it can't look forward it needs to
store the entire code of this function f
so all it needs to basically build this
map if a is 1 then this if a is 2 then
this if a is 3 then this store that in
the hidden state and then once a comes
around in the next time step this can be
resolved you can see that this is
infinitely more complicated than simply
looking forward and outputting the value
yourself so that's sort of the
difference in power that these two
formulations are talking about ok so
yeah two parts to this paper first part
linear transformer through kernels
second part if you formulate it like
this
it is equivalent and so a autoregressive
transformer in this way becomes
equivalent to an RNN and here is some of
the output samples you know they're
they're pretty pretty good though if you
look at the more output samples they
have here it so here this this is the
linear one and you can see for example
it's already in this very bottom one
this one right here it's the kind of all
the other transformers get the slant to
the right and that be
the original has whereas this one is
simply straight I mean I don't want it I
wouldn't want to dunk on this like these
others make a lot of mistake mistakes
right here but here I also saw you know
all of them get that this is going to be
the number three while this one is
somehow making this circle in here so it
is not perfect and even though it's on
par aware in the tasks they see you can
see right here that especially in this
speech recognition the original
transformer right here is significantly
outperforming the linear transformer
which is the one in black right here in
fact in all of the tasks but ultimately
it might not matter because they reach
you know the same they reach the same
they reach the same accuracy or whatnot
and the linear transformer is way way
faster so I can see that this is going
to be a I think that people apply I
guess time will tell
right I invite you to read the paper
tell me what you think I might be
totally wrong here with any of my
formulations or my intuition about what
this new attention mechanism does yeah
please let me know and I'll see you next
time bye bye